der aktion benni könnte im jahr 2000 167
auf die erde stürzen die folgen wären
fatal
konkrete details über benno sehen uns
bislang kaum bekannt doch das könnte
sich letzte nacht geändert haben die
raumsonde osiris rex hat nämlich ein
touch and go manöver ausgeführt um
proben zu entnehmen ist das manöver
geglückt und wie soll ein möglicher
asteroideneinschlag in gut 150 jahren
verhindert werden
klicks zum science and future gibt es
dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen kleiner
gemeinschaft l m bekommt ihr die videos
früher und zuverlässiger als ihr auf
youtube einfach hier auf das sie klicken
und nie mehr ein video verpassen
probiert es einfach mal aus das war eine
unglaubliche nacht mit live bildern oder
er quasi live bildern aus einer
entfernung von 290 millionen kilometern
mehr als eine viertel stunde benötigten
die signale zur erde
der hass ist einer von hunderten
potenziellen kandidaten die auf die erde
stürzen könnten und einem solchen
asteroideneinschlag sind wir momentan
noch schutzlos ausgeliefert
den riesen brocken bendel zählt die nasa
zu den gefährlichsten aller bekannten
asteroiden die mit der erde kollidieren
könnten berechnungen zufolge könnte er
beim vorbeiflug am 25 september 2001 135
der erde tatsächlich gefährlich nahe
kommt näher als der erdmond das wiederum
könnte seine weitere flugbahn so
verändern dass er noch im selben jahr
100 mit der erde kollidiert dazu der
forscher patrick michelle vom pariser
observatorium windows bahn haben wir bis
ins jahr 2100 35 vorausberechnet dann
würde sich der erde bis auf ungefähr 280
1000 kilometer nähern danach ist ein
weiterer kurs unsicher sei davon abhängt
wie nahe er der
wirklich kommt und wie stark sie seine
bahn verändert unseren analysen zufolge
könnte er beim nächsten mal im jahr 2000
167 mit einer wahrscheinlichkeit von 1
zu 2700 auf der erde einschlagen und das
ist für einen asteroiden eine hohe
wahrscheinlichkeit mit so einer chance
würde ich nur zu spielen
eine studie aus 2009 berechnete eine
serie von möglichen zusammenstößen mit
der erde zwischen 2169 und 2199 doch die
genaue wahrscheinlichkeit für eine
kollision ist nicht wirklich ganz genau
zu beziffern
denn die physikalischen eigenschaften
des asteroiden sind noch weitestgehend
unbekannt
eine kollision mit benno hätte mit
seinem durchmesser von 500 metern und
einem gewicht von 87 millionen tonnen
ebenfalls fatale folgen beim aufprall
würde er nach berechnungen der nasa wohl
eine energie von 80.000 atombomben
freisetzen das entspricht einer
kinetischen energie von 1200 megatonnen
tnt uns bleiben also noch 100 jahre um
gegenmaßnahmen für diesen möglichen
asteroideneinschlag zu erarbeiten wir
hatten in diesem zusammenhang ja schon
mehrfach über die idee der nasa behörde
planetary die fans team berichtet
stichwort hemmer
das steht für high velocity escort mit
hübschen mission für merchants iris pons
winkel ein neun meter langes und knapp
neun tonnen schwere raumschiff das mit
einer delta 4 heavy in den weltraum
gebracht werden soll es könnte nicht nur
als transportmittel für eine atombombe
dienen sondern auch als rammbock eben
beispielsweise für benesch denn ein
kleiner schubs sagt könnte den us open
zu einer kursänderung bringen doch das
ist eben nicht die einzige strategie an
der forschungsteams weltweit tüfteln um
uns verbände zu beschützen denn derzeit
wird es auch um die raumsonde rosetta ex
extrem spannend und die erwartungen an
die mission sind alles andere als klein
astronomie teams hoffen auf
überlebenswichtige erkenntnisse für die
menschheit zunächst hat die sonde die
geologische zusammensetzung von benny
untersucht um zu wissen wie porös und
kompakt der brocken wirklich ist die
annäherung an den riesen brocken war die
erste phase der mission die polycom hat
benno kartografiert die kamera ist in
der lage objekte in der
größe eines kieselstein zu erfassen am
31 dezember 2018 hatte sich die sonde
dem asteroiden soweit genährt dass seine
schwerkraft gegen die anziehungskraft
der sonne gewann osiris rex ist damals
in eine umlaufbahn von bendel
eingeschränkt seitdem hat sie sich dem
us team bis auf 700 meter genähert der
suite wurde zentimeter für zentimeter
gescannt und dann jetzt der höhepunkt
der mission in der vergangenen nacht
wurde die sonde auf nur ein paar meter
abstand so benny abgesenkt sie fuhr den
roboterarm xm haus text steht dabei für
touch and go sample acquisition menschen
wissen was so viel heißt wie mechanismus
zur erfassung von proben durch berühren
und verlassen spricht keine richtige
landung sondern ein kurzes aufsetzen nur
mit diesem roboter die bilder davon
waren spektakulär die sonde berührt wenn
du mit dem arm nur fünf sekunden lang
dabei schoss sie stickstoff auf den
asteroiden und wirbelte staub und geröll
auf vorab wurde jeder quadratzentimeter
des asteroiden gescannt auch um einen
geeigneten platz für die materialproben
entnahme zu finden denn proben können
nur wahrgenommen werden wo kann
felsbrocken im weg liegt der landeplatz
muss also sehr sorgfältig gewählt werden
echtzeit daten zeigten heute nacht an
also echtzeitdaten mit einer viertel
stunde verzögerung dass das tags m
die oberfläche erfolgreich kontaktiert
und den inhalt einer seiner drei
gasflaschen mit stickstoff ausgestoßen
hat das gas sollte staub und
kieselsteine auf panels oberfläche
aufwirbeln von denen einige im text m
proben sammeltopf aufgefangen werden
sollten
das team von osiris rex bestätigte auch
dass die sonde kurz nach dem kontakt mit
der oberfläche seine triebwerke
abfeuerte und sich sicher von bennett
zurückzog
noch ist nicht 100 prozent klar ob diese
probenentnahme tatsächlich erfolgreich
war
die letzten bilder von osiris sechs
stammten von den momenten kurz vor der
probenentnahme trotzdem ist die euphorie
bei der nasa riesig das heutige tag
manöver war historisch sagte laurie glas
direktorin der planetary science die
vision am nasa hauptsitz in washington
die tatsache dass wir die oberfläche von
bendels sicher und erfolgreich berührt
haben zusätzlich zu all den anderen
meilensteinen die diese mission bereits
erreicht hat ist ein beweis für den
lebendigen geist
erforschung der weiterhin die
geheimnisse des sonnensystems aufdeckt
jetzt sollten sich mindestens 60 gramm
gestein in den proben kammern befinden
und 26 kubikzentimeter staub vom bendels
oberfläche möglich ist eine probe menge
von aber insgesamt 2 kilogramm
die gesammelten oberflächen daten und
diese proben enthalten informationen die
für das leben auf der erde im ernstfall
von immenser bedeutung sein könnten
doch auch andere super spannende
erkenntnisse könnte uns die probe von
benno bescheren
dazu der osiris rex forscher roberto
kempens diese primitiven asteroiden
verfügen über einen hohen anteil
organischer moleküle wenn wir verstehen
wollen wie das leben auf der erde und
vielleicht anderswo entstanden ist
müssen wir die zusammensetzung solche
asteroiden verstehen
in den nächsten tagen wird geprüft ob
und wie viel material entnommen wurde
allerdings hat es jedes rex zwei weitere
gasflaschen an bord und kann das manöver
also noch zwei mal ausführen im märz
2021 steht der rückflug zur erde an und
der dauert bis 2023 wenn er kein video
zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen dem
verpassen wollt dann erdet mich bei
telegramm dann umgeht er die etwas
unzuverlässige abo box hier auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video weil ihr
dort vorab garantiert informiert werdet
also hier draufklicken oder aus oder
unten in die video beschreibung und hier
geht es weiter mit gefährlich stars nasa
rammbock gegen bendel anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren und zwar dieses
video und diesen kanal und bis dann
bleibt dran